this is a graph of UK bond yields from
the last month after a tumultuous week
the market is starting to settle the
government announced Monday that it
would walk back part of its
controversial tax cut plan a move to cut
the top rate of income tax that in
addition to an emergency Bond buying
program from the bank of England helped
calm investors after the UK's Financial
Market was thrown into chaos last week
England's Central Bank looking to put
down a Revolt in the financial markets
there they did a dramatic intervention
today to try to calm the markets
following the turmoil after last week's
mini budget they worked through the
night and came up with an unprecedented
package at the heart of the crisis are
derivatives complex financial
instruments that allow investors to bet
on the performance of Assets in this
case government bonds well this was a
somewhat Niche part of the market but it
rippled out in ways that people really
didn't expect and in the end it was
potentially going to impact the entire
Financial stability for the UK here's
how this type of adjustment started a
ripple effect that risked creating
crisis level losses in typically quiet
corners of the market
look at where the bond crisis started on
September 23rd the British government
unveiled sweeping tax cuts as part of a
plan to kick-start economic growth
High tax rates damage Britain's
competitiveness they reduced the
incentive to work to invest and to start
a business the announcement spooked many
investors who responded by starting to
sell off their Holdings of government
bonds they're worried that they were
going to flood the market with new
issuance at a time when demand for UK
debt is already very low as well they're
concerned that it's going to stoke
inflation and make the bank of England
even more aggressive in raising interest
rates the sell-off Cent yields sharply
higher as bond prices fell bond prices
and yields are inversely related but
these changes didn't just impact
bondholders directly they also affected
investors like Pension funds who held
derivatives such as interest rate swaps
these are Financial contracts whose
values are tied to assets like bonds
they were doing a lot with borrowed
money it's called Leverage and in the
financial world and that means that you
can buy Hedges or protect against
interest rate swings or inflation very
cheap but that means also whenever
interest rates move like they did in
recent days really unprecedented moves
you're exposed many times over to hedge
potential losses derivatives contracts
often also require collateral from
investors usually this is held in the
form of cash or Securities like bonds
but cash is preferred contracts often
also require additional collateral to be
posted if those trades begin to lose
money for example if interest rates move
that was the case for some investors who
held these derivatives when bond yields
started to rise and because changes were
happening so quickly collateral was
requested on a tighter timeline than
usual normally you have maybe a week to
get that money to your counterparty in
this situation they were asking for it
within hours Pension funds that didn't
have enough cash on hand to put up for
collateral sold off some of their bonds
this created a feedback loop selling
more bonds drove down prices even more
which in turn resulted in more calls for
collateral which led to more bonds being
sold off
well I think what this showed is is the
risks of derivatives and trading with
borrowed money AKA leverage we've seen
this before in the financial crisis but
this was once again a reminder of how
quickly the market can turn around on
you and the widespread impacts I can
have on financial markets justifying its
intervention the bank of England said on
Wednesday were to function in this
market to continue or worsen there would
be a material risk to UK Financial
stability the bank of England will
continue to buy bonds through October
14th but effects from the crisis have
spilled into other markets so it's not a
long-term strategy there's a lot of
questions about what's happened what's
going to happen once they stop buying
those bonds I think this is serving as a
reminder of the risks that lie ahead as
central banks continue with their plans
to raise interest rates to combat
inflation
foreign